you're watching spectator tv you're
watching a special edition of spectator
tv
we're going to speak to anders tegnal he
is the swedish
epidemiologist who has been the
architect
of sweden's approach to covet which has
been very different
from most of the approaches elsewhere in
europe indeed elsewhere
in the world and that's why we're very
grateful that we can
talk to him today anders welcome to
spectator tv
thank you for coming back let i want to
talk
about where we are now but before i do i
want to just kind of look at sweden's
record
over the past six months now sweden has
had to date
580 covered related deaths per million
that's not far off britain 613
deaths per million nobody thinks
britain's been a success story in
handling this
uh covet so why should sweden be
regarded
as a success story i'm not sure anybody
of us can be
regarded as a success story yet i think
that's a very dangerous thing to say
we're all struggling we're all trying to
find ways to deal with this
very different kind of pandemic that
we're seeing in front of us
when it comes to the death toll i think
in britain and in many other places but
definitely in sweden
there is a very complicated background
to that you can't just look at the
figures you
also need to understand in what context
this happened
and we obviously had a clear weakness in
our
elderly homes the long-term care
facilities um
especially in the stockholm area and
some surrounding regions
and that proved to be a big problem when
it comes to kobe 19. it has been a
problem before with flu and with
antibiotic resistance and so on but not
nearly as big as it was now
so there was a big spread and in that
group of people over about 70 000 people
in sweden
most of them are very frail they have
multiple other diseases they're very old
and so
susceptible to be have a fatal kind of
disease
now when we have worked quite a lot with
those
long-term care facilities we are down to
almost no spread in them and that has
also meant that our death toll is down
to very low levels
of course we all wish that that could be
done earlier but this was a flaw in our
system
and that we partly knew about but didn't
really realize the complete
extent to what it would do to us
i appreciate the the picture is always
very complicated and
statistics don't always prove one thing
or caused by one thing
but what i'm trying to look at is
evidence that not having a lockdown of
the kind that britain had
or france had uh has been more
successful
uh than having a lockdown i mean
because sweden has fared worse than its
scandinavian neighbors
and they had lockdowns deaths per
million in norway
are just 49. that's less than a tenth of
sweden's
denmark's 110 that's less than a fifth
of sweden's
finland 61 just over a tenth
of sweden's i mean by these mess tricks
how could we regard sweden as
let's not say success as having done
well
yeah first of all you have to realize
the epidemic in sweden has been quite
different
to what it's been in our neighboring
countries due probably
to huge influx of people very early on
when
the stockholm area had its winter
vacation
and a lot of stockholmers came back with
the deceased and it meant that we have a
huge
start of it and there was absolutely no
way we could have handled it the way it
was handled in finland and norway
because there was just too many cases
so when i talked to my uk or my dutch
colleagues they describe the pandemic in
the uk
and in the netherlands which is very
similar to the way it developed in
sweden
so i think that's a much more relevant
comparison to have and there you can say
okay
so what difference did a lockdown do we
don't really believe
a lockdown might have done a lot of
things and might have slowed down the
pandemic but
it would probably not have saved very
many people in in our elderly homes
because these people need
constant contact with the surroundings i
mean they need several visits a day many
of them need
24-hour care and that's the situation it
is
you you mentioned that in the early days
so many of sweden's fatalities happened
in
care homes perhaps as many as 50 percent
of
in the early days i've seen but even if
you take out swedish care home
fatalities
take them out from the swedish figures
altogether
norway and denmark still had far fewer
fatalities
yes that's true but once again their
kind of pandemic at least so far
has been hugely different uh than the
swedish one
and and i think there's a number of
reasons to that i mean one reason is
that the pandemic started differently in
sweden in a way that especially in the
stockholm area there was no way that our
health system could
could handle it the same way they did in
norway and finland but also that we have
a
big population of migrants that are
in socioeconomic not so well
circumstances
which is much more similar to what you
can see in the netherlands and uk
those groups are very much smaller in
finland and norway and we can tell that
a lot of the fatalities and a lot of the
mobility early on
was in these groups we
look at sweden and always think it is
one of the finest uh
welfare systems in the in the world a
cradle-to-grave
system why anders was sweden so badly
prepared
when it came to care homes as as we were
in this country
but we've always known that our care
homes are the kind of poor relation
uh to our national health service why
was sweden so badly prepared
maybe in a similar manner because
25 30 years ago the care homes were
moved away from the
hospital system and moved into the
social welfare system
and there were many good reasons for
that and it became much more of a home
for these people living there which i
think has many many
positive aspects but at the same time
the contact
to medical care medical expertise
medical
resources became very scammed and i
think that worked in normal
circumstances
but when there was a heavy kind of
health threat to them these the
loss of health practice in in those
became very apparent this has been
mentioned in in
several reviews over the years and we
discussed extensively what to do about
it
and we just had a meeting with the
commission that's going to look into
this
today and i think we're all clear that
at this stage
there really needs to be some dramatic
changes to to do that
to make these places a much safer home
in the future
it certainly i think is making every
country look at its care homes uh
now as a result of this now there was a
time
back in march when the british
government was thinking of following
sweden
with no lockdown then neil ferguson's
imperial college model forecast
500 000 deaths without lockdown
and it looked to us and from the outside
that the government then panicked and
said
that's it we need a lockdown was that
was the government
british government wrong to panic in the
face of these figures
i i don't think i can really review that
i mean every country has to sort of deal
with the situation they end up in and
there was a very dramatic
increase in in great britain at that
time and i can really understand
there was a great need to do something
in sweden the the increase was much more
gradual
and we managed to keep our health care
system running all the time i mean there
was always beds free for
any coal person who needed treatment
so the situation never really developed
that for in sweden and i think that's
why we
we managed to keep the track we started
on all through
the imperial modeling implied when some
uh swedish academics got hold of the
data
implied there will be 85 000 deaths in
sweden
with no lockdown why didn't you panic
a big party because we looked at the
model now and we could see that the
variables that were put into the model
were quite extreme
in our view and that was also done by
other academic people in sweden and we
all agreed
and that can of course be discussed
afterwards why did you choose the kind
of variables that gave these kind of
extreme results
so we were always quite doubtful that
this was really be the development and
we did some work on our own that pointed
in a quite different direction
and it in the end it proved that our
prognosis
were much closer to the to the real
situation actually very close to the
real situation
um probably because we really use the
data that we we felt that we could
understand and data that came from the
actual situation and we're not
coming from some kind of theoretical
model
so what you're saying is that the data
imperial put into the model
i mean there's the old thing rubbish and
rubbish out
that may be a little bit extreme but you
see my point you're saying that
you didn't trust the data that went into
the modeling
uh and you were right because there you
didn't have a lockdown
and you had nothing like 85 000 deaths
but i think you always have to be very
careful about models models are not
really made to do prognosis models are
made to test certain
different kind of measures that you take
and
try to see what kind of effect they
might have and so on and if you want to
use them as a prognostic model you have
to be very careful and
really look very careful with the in
data you look because as you said
rubbishing rubbish out and if you like
in this case don't really know
what kind of data to put in you have to
be very careful about what you
think about what the outcome is going to
be you must feel vindicated now though
in
not following the consequences of that
modelling 85 000 deaths in reality i
think
sweden at the moment is around 5 700 5
800 debt it's a it's a terrible amount
any debts a terrible amount
but it's nowhere near 85 000. no um
i i don't really like to talking about
vindication or not
this is not the competition we're not
trying to win any kind of award we are
just trying to do our best for public
health and try to keep
this pandemic in in a way that our
society can handle it
it makes me wonder though and it's not
really a question that you
you could answer it does make me wonder
if the british government
interrogated the imperial data going in
to the same degree that you did
yeah i mean i think that's a good
question for somebody to look into into
the future
indeed when you look at it and i'm i
probably understand you don't want to
give advice to britain or anything like
that but
at least theoretically on the basis of
sweden's experience
could should britain have avoided a
lockdown
i um as as you said and as i said before
i
i don't really feel comfortable
reviewing what's happening in different
countries
i'm sure we're all trying to do our best
in the circumstances we have
but i think if we could have had a
little bit more of openness and we could
have had some more discussion
on a tactical level between different
countries before all of these decisions
were taken
i think we could override something
together that that
maybe would have worked slightly better
than the situation that we see right now
let's look at where we are right now uh
yesterday
spain announced eleven thousand new
cases france
over ten thousand new cases the united
kingdom about three thousand new cases
are we at least in these countries and
these parts of europe
are we now in a second wave of covet
there's a lot of discussion if you
should call this a second wave or not i
mean
kovit is different than the flu when it
comes to how it spreads it spreads much
more heterogeneously it spreads much
more in clusters
but obviously this is the second kind of
increase of the number of cases it is
kind of
probably a kind of covert second wave
which is
of course different than a flu second
wave and
definitely is causing and probably also
will cause a lot of harm
in many countries still and it
definitely gives us the signal that this
pandemic is far from over
but new swedish cases uh
yesterday we were only 224
versus 11 000 i say in spain over 10 000
france 3000 the united kingdom
why only 224 in sweden
as many questions only the answer lies
in the future i mean there's of course
at least two different ways to look at
it one is maybe we are
a bit earlier in the phase than many
other countries
our downturn on the curve came later
so maybe this is something that's still
going to happen in sweden we don't know
on the other end i think there is a big
difference and the big difference is
that we haven't had a severe lockdown
that we open up
we have had the same measures in place
all the time sustainable measures we
believe
even if the population is getting
slightly tired also in sweden
but having the same measures in time
gives a bit more stability stability to
the development
and i hope and i think that's what we're
seeing right now
so just to be clear in layman's language
is it broadly
your case that because you don't really
have people coming out of it you didn't
have people coming out of lockdown
because you weren't really in lockdown
you had some restrictions of course
not the kind of lockdown britain of
france spain had
that because of that you might be able
to avoid the kind of second wave
we're seeing in other countries yeah we
sincerely hope that i think we have
reasonable reasons to hope for that
we'll still see probably outbreaks here
and there in sweden we have seen a few
small ones so far
but now we have a lot of systems in
place we do a lot of contact racing we
do a lot of testing and we
managed to break the transmission chains
around these small outbreaks very well
so far and
we really hope we can continue like that
and it looks good right now
am i right in thinking that looking back
that you you had something that could
have been seen as a second wave in june
that
you had got on top of the figures and
then they started for a while to get
worse again
no that was all of it due to a huge
increase of testing we went from maybe
20 000 tests a week to 80 000 tests a
week
and of course then we found a lot of
cases that we haven't found before
so that that's completely an artifact
caused by increased testing
i see only 13
covert related cases are in intensive
care now in sweden
the seven day average of covert related
deaths is zero
zero what are you now predicting in
sweden for the autumn
i'm going on into the winter yeah
as i said what we believe in what we're
hoping is that we're going to continue
with this fairly low level of spread
that we have right now
and that but we that we most likely is
going to have outbreaks in in different
places we have a few in ice hockey teams
right now and
and young adults in general a little bit
here and there but very small
but that we will be protected by the
measures we have in place
with the help of some level of immunity
in the population
and also we have a lot of resources in
place to take care of these
small outbreaks now in a completely
different manner than we could do this
spring
many governments including the british
government are now tightening controls
again local lockdowns are proliferating
local lockdowns in britain now
cover about 30 million people areas
where 13 million people live there's
even
talk of a second national lockdown in
government
circles when you see that what do you
think what do you say
to that i i'm
i really understand that now when you've
seen what this
disease can do i mean the death toll we
had in many countries and so on that you
really want to have something in place
that you can stop this
up search that we see all over the place
uh if it needs to be complete lockdown
so you can do it in a with a bit more
maybe what you can call a surgical
precision
uh i think that remains to be seen i
mean in sweden we'll try to work
very much with a little bit more
position in areas where
we do know that there is a risk of
spread that's why we have been quite
clear about restaurants they need to
have a service in place that does not
include
or prevents crowding and prevents
spreading those places and we have
really cut down on
big events and so on and so far that
kind of a little bit more precision
like instruments have proven quite
effective in sweden
just a few more questions since i've got
you here you
you always deny that herd inherit
immunity was your policy
but i've seen you say that widespread
immunity
is now helping to explain the recent
drop in swedish cases so
is it not de facto her immunity
has been the policy no not the policy i
mean
because that always sounds like we are
prepared to sort of sacrifice people
to arrive at something we are definitely
prepared to sacrificing people in the
swedish system that's completely
opposite to
what we have as a goal in public health
but
you cannot deny and i think no nobody in
the world denies that if you have a
reasonable amount of people that you're
immune in your population that will slow
down the spread
and will definitely increase the
effectiveness of any kind of measure you
put in place
what did you make just on that an
article in the british medical journal
it was published only yesterday i'm not
sure you've seen it yet it says
that about half of us could have t cell
immunity
to corvid which is as i understand it
separate to the
anti-body immunity is it is that
possible and would that be
encouraging that would of course be
encouraging that we already have such a
big part of our population immune to it
i not it wouldn't really fit in the
models we have used so far because
we don't really we wouldn't really have
had the spread that we see
if that big part of the population were
immune already from the beginning
and we can at least yeah i mean
i think the the judgment on that is
still out there might be something in it
how big of an effect it has remains to
be seen
the problem with t-cell immunity is that
it's very difficult or not very but it
takes a lot of resources to measure it
and that's why it's not been done in a
in a big
time yet we have done some at the
karlinsky institute
pointing in a similar direction but if
it's really going to help us or not
i think in the future we can only tell
that
do you have an idea of what percentage
of the swedish population
is now likely to be immune
it's been proven to be very difficult to
measure because
the spread is so heterogeneous so when
we measure in different population we
get
figures all the way from 30 percent of
the population in some areas to
stockholm to down to five percent among
the blood donors in
in the south of sweden we believe that
in the stockholm area maybe somewhere
between 20 and 30 percent
on the national level maybe around 15
but this is
just guesses based on fairly scant data
so far
two more questions one that one of our
viewers asked me to ask you and he
wanted to know what would happen if we
allowed all
non-vulnerable people to carry on life
as normal during a second spike
but we super isolated the elderly and
the vulnerable
so now there was no lockdown for the
majority of the population
is that is that a possible course of
action
i think it's very very difficult because
it's very difficult to isolate
different parts of the population from
each other like that i think all our
experiences proved that we have now
managed to
fairly well isolate this small 70 out of
80 000 people of the
sort of most vulnerable in sweden but
that has taken a lot of effort
and it's very difficult the sort of half
isolation we have made for the
above 70s in sweden has proven to be to
take quite a big toll on that
group because they really feel isolated
there's a lot of
mental problems and so on in that group
so i don't
i don't think it would work and i think
that the consequences would also be
probably more than we would like to to
think about
the british government is worried that
christmas
as we've known it might be cancelled
i don't think that's happened since the
days of oliver cromwell
uh in britain in sweden you're now
talking about
letting people visit care homes again
and
the size of gatherings could go up from
50 to perhaps 500
will therefore be something like a
normal christmas in stockholm
it depends on what you mean with a
normal christmas i think the the kind of
normal christmas that you celebrate
within your family
that i think to a certain extent or hope
to that we can
have with proper measures in the home
and try to
take special measures with our elderly
relatives
but once again yes we are allowing
visits to the early homes but
we are giving very strict advice on how
they should be done
once again we try to to you to do this
with a kind of position so we we take
away the risks but we
let things happen and the same thing
with increasing the amount of people
from 50 to 500
yes we say it's okay with 500 if you do
it in a place where people have assigned
seats that at least want me to report
from each other
and that you can arrange entrance and
exit in a way that there are no crowding
so yes we are opening up but we are
opening up with a lot of care
not to cause any undue problems sounds
like we might be coming to stockholm to
join you for christmas anders
you're always always welcome my swedish
wife will be very happy if we do
that uh anders techno thank you for
joining us on this
uh spectator tv special and for going
through
uh a difficult time uh these issues that
i know you've been grappling with thank
you very much
thank you for having me
[Music]
you